aim Kareem is an idyllic corner of West
Jerusalem this is where sister Maria
alfonsín got us the founder of the
Rosary sisters spent her childhood and
the last year's of her life born in 1843
under Ottoman rule
sister Maria alphonsine died here in
1927 today sister Agatha looks after
Marie Alphonse Singh's house she was
from Palestine from Jerusalem she was a
daughter of this country that's why it's
an honor for us that she's been
canonized had that shot of our demons
out of it to be a lil enough time stands
still in sister Marie Alphonse singh's
room the order has preserved her rosary
her letters and even the luggage she
used on her travels through Palestine
and Jordan a picture of Mary the mother
of Jesus hangs on the wall sister Marie
alphonsine had repeated visions of Mary
and the visions Mary told her to found
the order of the Rosary sisters no easy
task for a woman in 19th century
Palestine she was a very modest woman
very shy but also well educated for her
time she joined a convent at an early
age and was 40 by the time she
established her new order she founded
this orphanage back in 1917 32 years
earlier she was said to have
miraculously rescued a girl from a well
further miracles were to follow her
canonization is being watched closely by
the Middle East's Christians ma a.m. I
think that God wants to send us a
message to tell us to concentrate on our
prayers peace will then spread in
Palestine Israel Iraq Syria and other
Arab countries and peace will put an end
to all the awful events they had in had
less ordered the sisters of the Rosary
remember their founder in the same
Chapel in which sister Maria Fon seen
once prayed
legacy lives on through the order and
the many schools orphanages and
hospitals she established across the
region